envoyez vous avez monté ça quelle année
vous l'avez fait en 1999 20 ans il ya
quelques semaines le 5 mai 20e
anniversaire bon alors oui c'est
dangereux que vous le saviez
à l'époque que vous l'avez fait c'est un
sport extrême s'est conclue y laisser sa
vie mais à ce point là autant de morts
qu est ce qui se passe c'est cet
engouement qui a vers l'everest
les vrais ça ce pouvoir des mains le
plus fort qui existe dans le monde de
l'avant sur et aujourd'hui les gens y
vont et en trop gras non à mon avis mais
le népal devrait peut-être être un petit
peu plus sévères sur la sélection mais
observez le népal un pays pauvre
les permis que vous avez dit en
introduction de reportage c'est pour une
350 permis c'est beaucoup d'argent pour
le népal et le regarde pas toujours si
les alpinistes qui s'y présentent ont
l'expérience nécessaire et il ya des
mauvaises raisons pour grimper l'everest
yanagi bonnes et les mauvaises raisons
et en a beaucoup qui s'obstine et qui
veulent se rendre ou sommet à tout prix
est d'ailleurs lorsque les gens monsieur
warren trop dresse inconsidérés qui
n'ont pas l'humilité et même le courage
d'affronter une défaite et de
redescendre écouter ils sont à 100 m la
fameuse photo où on voit 7 millions $
voire cerf-volant ou un sas et 100
mètres sous le sommet c'est à dire que
encore juste un petit peu plus haut
certains clp nice peut voir d'autres au
sommet en train de célébrer voilà tech
royal ça ouais y'a aulas il voit les
gens célébrer là haut mais 100 m ça
prend une heure il faudra une heure donc
pour faire les derniers sans mal une
heure pour revenir grâce à cette zone de
haute altitude ya bien un manque
d'oxygène démission pression d'oxygène
on appelle la zone de la mort du fait en
bouteille vous avez un apport très peu
après je vais vous l'expliquer autrement
je vous êtes installé dans un saloon
charge à 8500 mètres puisse prend soin
de vous mais vous n'avez pas soif vous
n'avez pas froid vous n'avez pas faim
tout va bien
3 4 jours vous êtes morts parce qu'ils
y'a pas assez d'oxygène à ces altitudes
là pour survivre le corps n'a pas aucun
moyen dit mot paul beeston d'athlètes et
je vous promets pas que ça rien à voir
le corps humain n'a pas la capacité
s'adapter à ces altitudes là quand tu
veux beaucoup de monde comme le sur la
photo le tas de monter et trop lent trop
lent donc les gens map andy murray mais
est ce qu'une avalanche il peut pas
avoir de valence vous êtes au sommet il
peut pas tomber de la neige du plus haut
et ils sont tombés dans le vide non ils
sont morts comment ils sont morts
d'épuisement de ne plus être capable
il décède après avoir atteint un sommet
quelques fois donc il ya vraiment une
congestion voilà cette année aucun
basses eaux non leur annoncer que la
mousson parce que vous le visant dans
notre jeu qu'on ne peut pas grimper
l'everest mais porte car rien de pire il
sait comme le temps des sucres même
période au printemps il y en a une autre
l'automne donc on leur annonce et vous
alpine est ce que la mousson devraient
être devant ces satanés eu quinze jours
plus tôt l'aïe sosie on part on essaie
on essaie parce que la fenêtre de france
rétrécie
alors il ya de plus en plus nombreux ce
qui fait une congestion pas ce qu'on
pourrait croire par ailleurs que les
équipements sont meilleures les temps de
son meilleur les les vingt ans allait
les bouteilles d'oxygène ce que vous
dites c'est super j'en voyais monsieur
roy je voyais en introduction une photo
de mener la vie j'ai eu le privilège
l'honneur de rencontrer quelques
reprises prendre le thé chinois nouvelle
zélande
lima vézy ceci bernard mêmes ou si tu
mets des eaux clé des gore-tex dit si tu
tombes dans une crevasse de 301 m c'est
pas ton petit leur texte va s'ouvrir et
donc bien partie inhérente de danger a
livré ce qu'il y fait ce sera toujours
mais il ya cette attraction de certains
de dire je veux me rendre sur le toit du
monde et lui aussi
c'est devenu assez commerciales les
entreprises les banques les pins porte
d'exemple les entreprises 11 i
la grande banderole alors d'entrer
gilbert a même nous un sommet une grande
pression de la part des commanditaires
ou de fondations je veux grimper
l'everest pour pour un enfant malade
leur faut que j'y aille où j'arrive
quand je réussis ce que je réussisse
trop de pression contrôle de pression
alors que c'est l'exception de se rendre
au sommet en principe lancé l'exception
et quand je vois dans mon là nous étions
neuf au sommet 9
pas de sens jamais je n'irai dans ces
conditions et vous est-ce que vous
auriez était capable d'arrêter votre
ascension si vous aviez ces antiques de
votre vie était vraiment en danger ou
xavi cette folie des hauteurs qui vous
pousse à y aller
écoutez je vais retourner parce que
l'everest
il sera toujours même l'an prochain et
dans deux ans et de par l'expérience
parce que j'avais des cheveux blancs
déjà lorsque gprs et vous savez pas
encore vous est trop jeune
la sagesse viendra brassage toujours
plaisir de vous parler merci durable et
à la prochaine
au revoir